If I'm trying to sell you a burrito you
don't want.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Trying to keep cutting the price doesn't
make you want the burrito.
>> If anything, you make it makes it kind
of worse if you keep discounting it cuz
like what's wrong with this burrito?
>> Yes.
>> All right. Welcome to Delton Plus
Michael. Today we're going to talk about
startup sales and specifically
mess ups, screw-ups, misconceptions.
It's like I think that uh instead of
trying to make a sales 101 style video,
we want to make it more entertaining by
telling about when people screw up and
uh that's always the most fun stuff. So
when you're in office hours with the
founder and you're just sitting here,
you know, you're hearing kind of kind of
a a hoham story, something didn't work
and then like you just hear something
that makes you cringe. you're just like
tell an example of that like where
you're just like oh look
>> I certainly was the type of founder who
>> wasn't excited about the concept of
sales and I had a lot of cartoonish
ideas about what sales looks like right
you picture like a used car salesman or
an insurance salesman or just like a
high pressure um time share salesman oh
you love those right and so I'm like man
I never want to do that that's bad
>> yes
>> I think that founders
may resolve themselves they need to do
sales like it's a ne necessary thing
>> but they deep down are still thinking
about the used car salesman somewhere
>> it's like they never had a canonical
example of good sales
>> it's like this it's that good sales is
so good it doesn't feel like sales
>> like think about service providers you
know I I've had good service providers
>> you just kind of email them with a
problem and they're like yeah
>> you have a problem like let's fix it
let's do the thing that you want to do.
Yes.
>> And they're super responsive and they're
really nice and they understand where
you're coming from. Yeah.
>> And those people are totally making
money off me.
>> Those people are selling me a product.
But when I'm interacting with these
people, it feels like they're not a
friend, but it feels like someone that
knows me. They understand me.
>> Yeah. A partner.
>> I present a problem to them and they're
in a position to help me with a good or
service.
>> Yes.
>> And we both walk away feeling really
good about the the transaction.
>> Yes.
>> That's good sales.
>> Yes. And it's so good that it would
never register in my brain is that's a
saleserson selling me something.
>> Which is so weird because I'm like is
there isn't another word for that. Like
there isn't like another word. It's just
it's almost like oh this was all my
idea. Like this was all like
>> I think for me the thing that makes me
cringe when the founder basically is
like you know I think I figured out a
little bit of what the customer's
problem is. It's gonna be really hard to
solve
and like
I don't think I can solve it, but I
still need to sell them something.
They're kind of talking to well like
maybe we can help them with this thing
or they, you know, I know what their
problem is, but they're asking for this.
I'm not gonna help them with the thing
that's screwing them up. I'm gonna help
them with this other thing. I'm trying
to figure out how to get out of here
with doing the least amount of work
possible and get paid. I'm not trying to
do this like trade, right? Like like the
very concept of trade where sales comes
from is like by trading goods we both
end up better.
Like I'm not actually engaging in trade.
Yeah,
>> I don't want to say I'm engaging in
theft, but like
>> if we were to look at the utility, if
you sell something to somebody that
doesn't produce any benefit to them, but
you make money in the end,
>> I don't think the word for that is
trade. I know, I think it's a different
word from that. I have to think about
what that word is.
>> It's a different word.
>> I think it's a different word,
>> but it's like so common. I think that's
the thing that really gets me. It's just
this like, oh, we're I'm not being
selfless. I'm not trying You described
this great like, oh, I emailed someone.
They tried to help me. They did help me.
I paid them. Great. Yeah. But so often
it's the exact opposite. It's like, oh,
like I'm trying to get paid and I don't
know if I can help. My mental model for
someone just starting out doing sales is
you have this, you want to just go talk
at someone and cram it down their
throats and get them to say yes. And so
it's usually a monologue.
>> Yes.
>> And you say a bunch of stuff and you
list the features. Another thing is like
often founders will think that
discounting is the most powerful weapon
they have. They'll be like, "Well, I
offered them a huge discount." And if
they bought now, they get a discount.
And again, when you think about it, if
you don't want something, like, if I'm
trying to sell you a burrito you don't
want.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Trying to keep cutting the price doesn't
make you want the burrito.
>> No. No.
>> If anything, you make it makes it kind
of worse if you keep discounting it
because like, what's wrong with this
burrito?
Well, and especially in those
situations, it's so clear the customer
doesn't realize that they can get any
value out of the product that like why
are we talking about pricing?
>> It's I don't even you do
>> exactly like I don't even know why this
would help me. And it's almost like I'm
trying to speedrun. It's weird to me
that like the process of helping someone
has been turned into this torturous
process.
>> Yep.
>> It shouldn't feel like torture. you
should be trying. Why else are you doing
this business if you're not trying to
help people?
>> Yeah.
>> Like,
and I and I think at core,
>> a lot of people are better at sales than
they realize. And it's getting them
>> to like put the car salesman thing out
of their mind
>> and think about it to to picture
>> what their best sales experiences were
of someone helping them with a problem
and to just emulate that. And I think
often people have an aha moment when you
say it that way, the way we're talking
about it.
>> Yes. And that's what you need to be like
the the founders I know that are best at
sales
>> are good at listening and not saying
much and being really empathetic and
then truly solving the problem so that
it feels like a relief to the customer.
>> I think you said it best. Good sales is
good problem solving. And any good
founder is solving how many problems in
their company every week? And if they
took that exact same
feeling into the sales conversation,
they'd be so, you know, it's like, are
your employees having a problem with
productivity and yada yada yada? And
you're like, hm, like, let me figure out
how to get this guy to like get out of
my face without helping me at all. Like,
that's not how you're thinking. It's
like, oh, maybe being more flexible at
this, maybe we can help you here. I
think that like if you take the core
assumption that often times the customer
doesn't know how to solve their problem.
So, the other thing that I see people
try to do in sales is like, great,
Dalton, give me a list of things you
want me to do. I'll do them. That will
obviously make your business better
because you gave me the list.
>> Yep.
>> And then we will both profit. And it's
like, how often are you selling
customer? The customer is like, well, I
want to make more revenue. I don't
really know how. Or a customer even
worse, I'm talking to somebody who
doesn't really understand the whole
business they're in. And like, hey, can
you help me do X, Y, and Z, but you
realize it's not going to really help
the business that they're operating.
That's a problem solving situation if
you treat it that way.
>> I mean, this is like trit advice, but
like a lot of trit advice, if you
pretend like you're hearing it for the
first time, it might hit differently.
So, this is one of those things which is
put yourself in the shoes of a customer.
>> Again, you're usually like, "Yeah, yeah,
put myself in the sho." No, but really
pretend like you you've never heard that
before.
>> Yes.
>> Pretend like this is the first time
someone's ever said that.
>> Yes.
>> Actually take a minute and it's almost
like a method actor. Yeah. Like, pretend
you're that person walking into the
room.
>> Pretend you can see their email inbox.
Pretend you can imagine what their boss
is telling them they should be worrying
about
>> what their next meeting's going to be.
>> Yeah. Like actually take a moment and
sit with that advice.
>> A lot of people aren't doing that is
where I'm going with this. Like they
they're like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah." You
know, put yourself in the shoes of a
customer. But they they actually have
never done that exercise. My version of
that is imagine you were the CEO of the
company that's buying your product.
what would you think? And it's so
interesting when I have that
conversation with people because first
of all they're just like because then
I'm like okay tell me about the business
of your customer, right? Because like
you're selling this product to them,
it's going to help their business. Tell
me about their business. They're like
anything about their business. And like
okay, like well if you were the CEO of
this business like what do you think
your top three problems would be?
They're like I have no idea. It's like
would your product be a solution to any
of the problems in the business? Like
I'm just trying to sell them marketing
software, Michael. Like why are you
making this more complicated than it has
to be? And I'm like, are you trying to
help your customer or are you just
trying to accomplish your goals and your
customer's goals are incidental? You can
certainly get somewhere with that
mentality.
You can you can probably raise your seat
round. You could probably hire people.
You could probably raise your series A,
right? Like like there's a whole set of
milestones you can have with that, but
like you'll never win unless one day you
you like wake up from this slumber.
Basically, you fix this. like this is
like a
>> yes
>> you might get pretty far never figuring
this out but one day you probably need
to figure it out.
>> Yeah. I think that's the thing that
confuses a lot of our founders is like
they see these products. I mean I've had
this conversation with founders like we
use the product it sucks.
>> Yeah.
>> We don't like it but they're doing well.
Maybe we should do what they do.
>> Yep.
>> Cuz like if you can only see two or
three steps ahead of you, you might be
following or copying company with a bad
product and thinking that's how you win
and it's like yep.
>> No. Oh, and the other side of that is if
a company is winning, you might not
understand the value they create for
their customers, but don't dismiss it to
zero.
>> Well, that's the classic thing of um
dismissing a product because the design
is bad.
>> Yeah, man. This HRS looks like crap.
>> I don't I don't know if that's the
higher bit here.
>> No, I totally agree with that. Here's
another fun one. I I'll give you a
scenario. Great. I'm doing my company.
I've raised a little bit of money. I've
done some sales. Now it's time to hire
VP sales, right? Because like that's a
whole thing. That's not my specialty.
I'm just a founder. Like I can hire
someone and they'll build a sales team
and they'll do it.
>> It's just that easy.
>> Isn't that how company building works?
>> Yeah. You just hire someone and they do
a perfect job and you you ride off into
the sunset.
>> Right. Right. Like the the title is VP
sales. It seems like they'd be good at
sales, right?
>> What do you think actually happens? Like
when a company does well, what is
actually going on? The deal with
executives, and we've talked about this
in other videos, you want them to
function at a at a high level, and
they've probably had a similar role in
the past. Yeah. And what it actually
means in practice is running a team and
hiring other people and managing those
people.
>> Yeah.
>> But it usually doesn't mean figuring out
from first principles how to do sales.
The most common source of problems is
that the founder just expects a new VP
of sales to come in and just do as good
of a job as the founder was doing or the
better not doing a good job
>> and just like know what to do.
>> Yeah.
>> And like that's not at all what they're
really prepared for. Like imagine
someone was a former VP of sales at at
Google or something like that. That's a
successful product with a successful
machine and they were trained and so
they were super effective at like
running a team and hitting their quota.
Yeah.
>> But if you're like a
>> new startup and that hasn't been around
for a while without an established
playbook, it's not obvious those skills
transfer over one to one. I can I state
that more strongly? It is obvious those
skills do not translate.
>> Those skills definitely do not
translate. I mean they could like
they don't tend to.
I think what's interesting about this is
as we have funded more B2B companies
over the years and I think personally as
I've realized that like every B2B
company is just an enterprise company or
not every the vast majority are just
enterprise companies that haven't
figured out their enterprise companies
yet. I think one of the things that
founders have a misconception on is just
how personally involved the CEOs of
enterprise companies are in sales.
>> Yeah. And I remember talking to we have
a bunch of founders from Palunteer and I
remember just being like, "Hey, you
know, you have these deals. Palunteer's
getting these crazy deals like da da.
How does some junior salesperson
originate a hundred million dollar deal
with Boeing? Like how do they even get
in the room with the right people? It's
PLG, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's different, right?
That Boeing came on the website, signed
up, right? What was really interesting
to me was like how much
executive sponsorship and executive like
founder level, CEO level involvement
there is in those deals
>> and how much the CEO is originating them
or is scouting for them is kind of
handing them back to a team to kind of
process a little bit but then like
debugging anything going wrong. It's the
exact opposite of let me hire someone
and look the other way. It's like the
sales organization is almost built
around y the founders and as a as almost
like a a multiplier effect on their work
as opposed to built to the side of them.
And you know I get these questions from
founders who you know their employees I
got this great question from employees
like how do I meet with this important
CEO myself and I'm like you don't like
why would they meet with
middle manager salesperson the the CEO
of this company is going to have a hard
time getting this meeting.
>> Why aren't you asking yourself the
question how can I help my CEO get this
meeting? Can we reframe? Like that
doesn't mean it's not your deal or like
whatever. Like let's just separate
credit out, right? Like
>> just still get paid. Go ahead.
>> Yeah, fine.
>> You're good. Can we go for the most
effective solution, which isn't junior
sales guy meeting with CEO?
>> Yeah. And so this misconception is also
just kind of like this idea of like you
told me I should do sales as a founder,
but now that we've moved along, I can
give
>> I'm not I'm done.
>> Yeah.
Maybe the last one that I want to talk
about is consulting. So I'll bring up
still my favorite company YC never
funded Palunteer. I have been surprised
at how many founders will say some
version of well we don't want to do this
for the company because that's going to
be consulting. Well you know that
integration is going to take too long.
It feels a little too oneoffy. It feels
like consulting. It seems like
consulting is the weird boogeyman in the
room. almost as if you would assume that
YC has like thousands of companies that
have died because they did too much
consulting yet like I have have not seen
that. So what's going on?
>> Yeah. So this is one of those um phrases
that gets repeated so much.
>> Yeah.
>> That it feels like
>> conventional wisdom.
>> Uh yeah, it's like being like, you know,
love thy neighbor. You know, you just
said it. Consulting is bad. Don't do
consulting.
>> Let's pretend like we're hearing it for
the first time. Let's examine this with
fresh eyes. Yes.
>> I remember in my first startup
um when we were not succeeding
>> getting a meeting with Disney.
>> Yes.
>> Because to to cut through a bunch of
[__] They took many meetings to get
to this. But like at the heart of the
matter,
>> they wanted my startup to build a white
label social network so that big fans of
the Disney parks
>> could network and share tips with each
other so they could sell more tickets to
Disney. And they had to control the
whole thing. And like there's they gave
us a speck of all the stuff they wanted
us to build.
>> Yes.
>> To like control what people could say.
Like we said no even though it would
have been for millions of dollars
because that was consulting.
>> Yes.
>> Like it was literally a big company that
wanted my startup to not have a product
and instead outsource their entire R&D.
>> Yes.
>> Because I seem like a schmuck or I'm
sure they asked lots of people to do
this. And you know, if one out of 20
startups said yes to that deal,
>> good for Disney.
>> It's good for Disney. So, you can see
why Disney would try to do those. Um,
obviously, that would have been a
horrible idea.
>> Yes.
>> From my perspective, right? And
hopefully the people in the audience can
see why getting a million- dollar deal
for Disney to build a
>> just random piece of software that no
one else would ever want that's super
bespoke is like
>> obviously a really bad business. Yes,
>> that is the true heart of this advice,
which is just building super random
stuff for big companies is a bad idea.
However,
the amount of times founders say, "Oh,
that's consulting and dismiss it out of
hand." I think is way larger than the
than the specific example I gave you.
>> Disney's not running around asking
startups to build them [__] all the
time.
>> Yeah. And so I do think there's a
question under the do things that don't
scale rubric of, you know, it's it's
basically a gray area, friends. There's
a lot of gray area of what is consulting
and what is not consulting. Yes. And so
I would just try to be open-minded and
decide this on a case- by case basis
versus dismissing out of hand that you
shouldn't do something because it's
consulting.
>> That's a very measured approach.
>> Okay. Okay. I will take an unmeasured
approach. Just do consulting. Like nine
times out of 10 you're probably not
doing real consulting. Like you're
probably especially early you're
probably getting the opportunity to
learn about the problem and that is such
a unique opportunity and trust your
ability to productize over time cuz
we're giving this advice in mass right
so 10% of the companies will do this and
they'll die. I apologize.
And Michael, I don't like those odds,
man.
>> 90% will like
>> better than their 10% is too high.
>> 90% will will learn something. And and
all too often I reframe consulting as
like a deep integration is a deep moat.
A long sales cycle is a moat. Like a lot
of these things that people associate
with enterprise, you can't on one hand
say why does it take 80 years for
someone to get off of SAP and on the
other hand be like I hate long sales
cycles and deep integrations. It's like
that's the game, you know? It's like,
>> oh man, I want to win the Super Bowl,
but I hate [__] throwing the ball.
And it's like, well, man, come on. Like,
>> I'll go a step further. I secretly think
the reason why Palenterer doesn't have
more competition is because too many
people shy away from anything involving
that kind of sales process, that kind of
cycle, that kind of product. And if
Palanteer figure how to make this not
consulting, I feel like a lot of people
could figure
>> Well, I think you could argue that they
are doing consulting,
but they're able to make enough of a
margin and have enough scale. Well,
again, this is semantics, but I wonder
if this is a this is somewhere in the
gray area. I will challenge this.
>> Go ahead.
>> Disney wanted to pay you $10 million to
build this website, let's say. But let's
say you could build it in 3 days. Is
that consulting?
>> Probably not. But I think a big part of
what they wanted was the operations of
it and to do the moderation. It wasn't
just the building. Let's say you could
build and operate it with only 3 days of
work. So you certainly don't have
consulting margins at that point.
>> Yeah.
>> And you probably have figured out some
kind of base level technology that would
enable you to spin that up from nothing.
>> It would have been the opportunity cost
that it's like wait are we in the
business of making white label social
networks.
>> I'm not sure that was a good business,
>> but that doesn't mean it's consulting.
>> I agree. I'm just thinking this through.
>> Yeah.
>> I think sometimes people fall in these
these these pseudo tarpits. Yes. where
like you get revenue but it's like not
that interesting
>> to me it's actually not consulting
versus non-conulting at least within the
YC community it's so rare that I see
consulting happen yeah
>> I think it is more I am making revenue
not solving that much of an important
problem for someone I'm doing like
something myself in a corner and I'm
making money yeah
>> it doesn't generalize into something
that's exciting
>> I agree so anyways the big takeaway here
I want to steal two things to kind of
summarize. I think one is this concept
that like great sales feels like problem
solving. You should be in the business
of solving your customer's problems.
Otherwise, you shouldn't be doing this
and you won't win. If you want to win,
you should seek to consistently solve
your customer's problems. Um, and then
two, the very underpinning of business
trade is both sides have to end up
better at the end of a deal. Please
structure things in that way. Um, please
don't, oh well, we hit our 15% month
overmonth goal, so
I won. I don't know if you won. You You
>> Let's not worry about problem.
>> It's your problem to figure out whether
you won your problem, Michael. Uh, we'll
solve that later.
>> Understand that core principle like do
right by your customers. All right. Good
chat.
>> All right. Thanks, Michael.